okay boys I want to bring up something
an anime topic right that's right wow I
know wow but this one is this one I'm
actually excited for because D Don just
got announced for an anime holy [__] and
I'm so [__] hyped I just saw that as
because it's science Sor I know dude
what it's science Sor who's that it's uh
[__] what's his name the
animation uh or if the
sorryy basic basically basically the
weird Studio yeah are doing D and the
trailer looks sick as [__] I haven't
seen the trailer yet dude it's insane
yeah I actually got the chance to read
the first few chapters of Dandan on
stream and it is wild it's so good yeah
so if you don't know what Dandan is I
believe it's her Shen Jump Jump Plus
Jump
Plus uh and it's from one of the editors
no not editors assistant of the
chainsawman author tki
Fujimoto and I don't know what was going
on on in that studio when he was making
like chainsaw man or whatever or
whatever manga they were all working on
together but every artist or every
author has come from that studio has
just made like the mo like the weirdest
Banger mango his assistant don't miss
yeah yeah no one on that team has missed
so far cuz the other the other assistant
uh was um was he the guy who made um H
Paradise H Paradise oh wow yeah yeah so
they all come they all came came from
the same stacked group of
they don't miss yeah I really enjoyed
house Paradise yeah I did too I did too
and I think you'd really like d as well
cuz [__] wild especially if that
studio is making it I I me ping pong the
animation is one of my favorites it's
like from the first four devil man
crybaby I also love devil man crybaby
I'm trying to remember the [__]
director's name um what's what the
[__] his name m
m [__] masaa yuasa masaki M masaki yasa
masaki yasa yeah that's yeah that's it
that's it yeah I don't know if yuasa is
directing this one but it's from his
Studio yeah it's from his Studio sence s
uh so most most recently I actually saw
the uh I actually seen a few episodes of
the Scott Pilgrim anime that's oh yeah
it was the first episode of that yeah
yeah it's it's good was weird I I I it's
weird but I I kind of [__] with it I
thought it was an interesting take just
saw a lot of people on Twitter arguing
about it yeah I I I I didn't know about
like the arguments or the controversy
around it so I went to to it completely
blind um and I don't know what I was
expecting and I don't know whether I
liked it or not I yeah I mean I've only
seen the first episode so it's hard to
discern whether I like it or not but I
think I'm going to like it I don't know
that it is weird also saw that my anist
wouldn't label it as as anime yeah which
is dumb that to me is dumb they said it
wasn't intended for the Japanese
audience yeah and that's how they
decided something's anime if it's for
the Japanese audience which is bizarre
cuz Japan would he be like what the [__]
what are you talking about which is like
the weirdest mental gymnastics uh I've
seen yeah they'll do everything to just
say shit's not anime I don't know why
yeah they were like they were like oh
there must be something in here oh it's
uh it wasn't made by Japanese people
well actually it's got a Chris Evans in
here which makes it for white people
yeah no like this Scott Pilgrim uh takes
off is an anime it was made in it was
animated in Japan it was storyboarded by
Japanese people people it was basically
an all Japanese theme uh and you could
tell that because one of the biggest
things that bothered me about uh about
it was the lip flaps just didn't match
and I it was so obvious that the
recordings was done at a different times
from when the lip flaps were like
finished because this must be how like
Japanese people feel I don't know like
to like well in Japanese anime generally
the lip flaps don't always match up
they're not not nearly they're also
basic enough where it even if they don't
necessarily match up it still feels more
natural I guess yeah it works I don't
know how it works but it weirdly works
but they don't they don't really care
about the flaps having to match
perfectly but Eng we very much we do
care yeah and I didn't think I would
notice it until I started noticing it
and I then I couldn't stop noticing it
well now that you've said that I didn't
notice it while watching it and now I'm
going to so thanks for that yeah it was
it wasn't like every time but it just
like sometimes it would just like be
like a tiny bit off or something i' be
like ah this is what it's like watching
originally dubbed anime I guess this is
why I had a really hard time playing
Final Fantasy 16 in Japanese because
they lip synced it to the English voice
acting oh yeah so when I was playing it
and I saw the cut scenes I'm just like
[__] I can't concentrate on this because
they I can read the lips and they're
saying something else to what I'm
hearing and it's so off py I remember
watching Scott Pilgrim the movie and I
thought it was pretty good but then on
Twitter I keep seeing this thing about
him dating like a 17-year-old or
something and I'm like I don't remember
that my knives was 17 I she was
I think she was she was in high school
right that was that was the whole that I
guess so yeah yeah that was the whole
thing yeah I just don't remember that
being a big
deal I just remember watching it and I
was like I guess this when did when did
Scott belgam come out like the the
original movie cuz um 2010 yeah 29 2010
yeah holy [__] that was a long time oh
my God that was 13 years AG a good movie
yeah I I thought it was an amazing movie
it still is like one of Ed right I think
it's I think was on my 3x3 I think uh
for one my tto 22-year-old Scott P A Bas
play for un he is dating KN Chia
17 I do I totally forgot that yeah I
think the thing about the new Scott
Pilgrim anime that I couldn't get my I
couldn't fully invest into I guess was I
think I realized I really really [__]
like the film but also I think I'm
perfectly satisfied with the film yeah
had much and yeah yeah and Scott Pilgrim
takes off goes like a completely
different direction to the film it like
gives more time for to explore each like
evil X and whatever and actually less
time with Scott Pilgrim uh which is I
think a big thing that people were mad
about which is uh at least where I've
gotten to Scott Pilgrim is barely in it
at all it's always a gamble isn't it
when you have like a new adaptation of a
show that is you know highly praised
beloved and people expect the story to
go exact in that same direction and then
when they do you know they flip the dime
on and they're like actually we're going
to go in a slightly different direction
then people are like why why why would
you try and fix something that's not
broken yeah the anime is very highly
reviewed though yeah it's it's it's
Prett it's it's interesting definitely I
I I think it's it was just weird where I
was watching it and I was like I guess
I'm enjoying this but I think I'd rather
just rewatch the movie I was like I I
have I have my personal emotional
attachment to the movie and this is
going like a completely different
direction and I was like uh maybe I'm
just not maybe I just wouldn't be a fan
of the comics I don't know if this is
more faithful to the original comics in
the movie but I think the reason I
really like the movie was not so much
the storyline but just because of Edgar
Wes Ed I think that was the reason why I
really really [__] like Scott Pilgrim
um and this has a bit of quirkiness to
it but nothing that really compares to
the crazy [__] that Edgar Wright did
that's always scary though isn't it like
cuz you know I'm kind of feeling the
same way about the upcoming uh avatar
the Last air bender series like the live
action series the netfli one yeah
because it's yeah they're doing a proper
like not with [__] this time uh well
because the [__] Shaman live action
is the only thing we had and that was
the worst thing in the planet why do we
need to remake it I don't get why why
are we remake it I think it's just cuz
for a lot of people it's extremely
nostalgic and people actually want to
see like I don't know if people are
asking for it but I think I don't want
to see yeah but I think that I think the
creators of the series of the original
animation wanted to actually do like a
proper live action they want to like
bring it back in a way that they'd be
happy with I would uh I would be down
for it if it wasn't following the
original James Cameron story line
because I think the weird thing about
Avatar for me is wait wait James Cameron
oh we're talking about different avatars
yeah yeah wait what are we talking about
we're not talking about the blue people
Avatar we're talking about Avatar The
Last
Airbender
wait I was like hold up wait wait wait
wait that's why I was like they're
making an avatar TV show what I thought
they were already making four films of
this shito was bro was cooking on 5
minutes figing out what to say that took
me a second I'll be
like s off about
this why would they make a TV series
about already a liveaction movie that's
what I was trying to like get my head
around when cuz you were like oh they're
making have avar TV series that made
that's why I'm really worried I'm like
yeah yeah I can understand why you're
worried I'd be worried as well if they
were making a James Avatar James Cameron
Avatar TV series but I was about to like
defend it because I was like Avatar has
an interesting world that does oh my God
no I'm talking about the last air bander
[__] Jake Sully bro yeah you know I
think Jake Sully would be fine if he was
an earth bander you I can't I can't wait
to see Jake Sul in live action no no
they're remaking uh Avatar
oh God to be fair we probably should
have said that I did say that he just
listen you said Avatar you didn't sayar
definitely said last day okay I didn't
know they were making well didn't didn't
they already make a live action movie of
this yeah the shaman movie and it was
one of the worst rated movies like of
the 2000s uh so in my head in my head
I'm like I don't want I feel like it
just doesn't need a live action but but
then I said that about one piece to be
fair I did watch the uh the trailer for
it cuz they released the trailer for the
new one it I mean obviously it looks so
much better than the Sham movie like not
even a question and but I am like kind
of keeping a healthy amount of
skepticism to it as well because this is
like one piece has like the one piece
live action was the double-edged sword
CU it proved to audiences that live
action animations could work and now I'm
just like and now there's a scramble to
like remake all of these it's one
diamond on top a pile of dog [__] what I
mean it was the proof of concept that
all they need was one working example
you know what else is also a pro proof
of concept this year just making
original [__] like original movies have
been crushing it this year it's been
such a good year for like if you are a
Marvel and [__] dog [__] Disney uh
hater which I am uh I'm so happy or
movies been crashing it this year I
Oppenheimer I already know Oppenheimer
Bobby Bobby I don't Bob original
although I I the concept of the film is
original so I'll give it that you know
we've it's an original story the mon
film came out although it wasn't I
thought it was a bit long that it's done
really well uh there's a few other
movies this year that have done really
well but generally like a lot of these
big Productions that would only ever do
well have not been do not not so well
yeah which uh it's nice to kind of feel
like it's kind of changing a little bit
I and it's just showing that hey I think
audiences now I think we're they're
tired of remakes I think we're tired I
think as a collective audience we are we
just want new ideas we're not well
especially after all the [__]
liveaction Disney remakes as well it's
like I think that was the real nail this
year we've had the [__] Little
Mermaid remake uh you know and and even
then the original stuff feels so um uh
like regurgitative we had the Pinocchio
remake come out last pinio was pretty
good oh really I didn't see it it it's
like a totally different uh retelling of
Pinocchio wait they did a remake of
Peter Pan um this year what isn't that
isn't that uh like one of those like
garbage movies Pan and Wendy I'd never
even the [__] okay a side cuz nobody
gives a [__] uh what I did watch that
was uh very good and original and Anime
Pluto watch Pluto oh you finished it
yeah I finished it oh [__] only like two
episodes in uh really yeah I [__]
loved it I think it's probably my
favorite anime I've watched this year oh
dude it's it's man he doesn't miss it's
so [__] good and I know nothing about
Astro Boy uh I I didn't even know that
was supposed to be Astro Boy until I
finished it yeah that's but that's what
was so smart on urasawa when he was
riding Pluto is that he made sure that
you don't have to know anything about
Astro Boy
and and you you want to know something
like Pluto is probably like uh you know
it's it's a lot of common consensus that
Pluto is one of his weakest Works what
yeah and right right is that or Billy
bat and I'm like this is your weakest
fighter which I I I really liked it I
think the ending was a little little bit
rushed but the rest of it I I really
really liked yeah I mean I I remember
what seeing the first two episodes of it
I just
such he is such a master when it comes
to Building A Mystery and suspense it
was like the the pilot of episode was so
good I I just love the scene where they
had this kind of like Silence of the
Lamb kind of like interview with like
the robot that killed somehow so it's
it's kind of a Sci-Fi world where robots
are in human society and of course
robots can't K kill humans uh except for
one robot that has proven to be able to
kill humans in the past and have like
the Silence of the Lambs kind of like
interview with him [__] love that
character and that was such a that was
such like an interesting character he's
just so good at writing the most
interesting like villains as well like
cuz like I don't know how he cuz like
you know Monster obviously Johan is like
an amazing example of it but even you
know the robot character in Pluto like
he wrote he wrote monster yeah yeah he
wrote monster I didn't know that yeah he
wrote mon he did monster 20th century
boys yeah which are like considered so
yeah that's what you're going up against
oh [__] okay this man this man is go he
is the goat but like you know he's so
good at writing not only just like
interesting and multi-layered villains
but just villains that you it's it you
can take time with getting to know and I
don't know how he does it like and this
is one thing I've always been like
extremely uh fascinated with and have so
much respect for mystery writers and
stuff like that is that like the really
good mystery writers are able to build
up this mystery in a nice slow easy to
process way without it spoiling anything
yeah yeah there was such like faith in
you as the audience to to be engaged as
well that they didn't it didn't have to
go crazy right away it was very willing
to like allow you to kind of just be
like hey here's a little bit of what's
going on he can sprinkle just enough
hints to get you hooked where without
spoiling a large majority of why he like
liked it and he so good at that in an
age where a lot of anime kind of feel
like it's just kind of Rush rushed
together Samy and almost unintentional
uh everything felt very very intentional
in this show that every single he
doesn't waste any time yeah every part
of the show just felt amazing and I
really really enjoyed it and uh please
watch Pluto if you haven't it's amazing
it's definitely I don't know I don't
know where it would rank but it's
definitely like one of my it's going to
be I already know one of my favorite
anime of the year uh cuz I think one
thing I love about how he introduces
story is that he's one of the few people
who you can be like really invested in
this like main like a plot line and then
nowh he would just like switch to a
different character and you're like why
the [__] would I give a [__] about this
character who is he why does he matter
and then you get invested into the
separate story line and you're like oh
[__] I'm investing in this and then at
the end he's like actually this is why
this relates to the first story and
you're like holy [__] 20th century boys
was like nothing but that and it was
done so incredibly well like every
character as you said every character
and everything they said everything they
did had some kind of built up to like a
grounder story line and oh my God he's
so good he's so [__] that's why he's
the gold and it felt like a complete
package which I I really feel like I've
been missing a lot in anime lately where
I'm so used to watching half a season
and then it it gets delayed or whatever
and I that's because the conditions are
Dreadful right now but uh you know it
really felt like this one this show had
a time to cook really let it like it
came out when it was ready the came out
quite a while ago I think so they've
been they've been working on this for a
long long time it's a pretty old series
um but I've heard that I've heard that
if this one does well which go watch it
so it does do well 2003 came out uh they
they would like to adapt more of nuka's
Works 20th century boys when are we
getting an anime of 20th century boys
able to adapt his magnumopus in my
opinion which is 20th century boys I
will literally come that's not a
euphemism I will just come I I I
literally I will actually watch anime if
he does that even Billy bad as well
which is another fantastic UD manga like
if if they do a good adaptation of that
which might be a little bit harder just
because a lot of the characters are not
human in that uh but yeah people need to
read more OS [__] and like it's so
underrated I I like it when concepts are
explored like decently sometimes they
they they some shows try to talk about
morality and it comes from a point that
I just I really am like okay sure yeah
like hard to relate to oh yeah not even
hard to relate to but just it feels like
the the nuance the show is struggling to
express the idea like fully uh and it
really felt like this one kind of nailed
every single kind of like moral
conundrum it was trying to present to
you as the audience I really enjoyed it
so please watch Pluto cuz I want more of
his shows cuz I don't want to read it
and watch monster as well also a great
anime Monster's also F I didn't know
he's monster moner great monsters just
too slow though to it's kind of hard to
recommend it's a bit of a slow burner I
think episodes and 30 of them are very
slow I mean read the Manga manga is
probably better but read 20 centur boys
read I should read it read centy boys
isn't just my favorite manga I think
it's just my favorite story that's ever
been written uh genuinely like it's I
can't disagree with you on I mean it's
like from a critical perspective it's an
absolute Masterpiece but also for all
the ideas it explores it's just like
really personally related to me as well
um even the live action was good for
20th century Bo it's so weird because he
cuz he's a musician right so music was
like a big kind of like aspect in 20th
century boys uh and like the fact that
he just wrote a song in a manga yeah for
he wrote he wrote his own song for a
manga and I'm just
like I respect it but how how where the
[__] did you get this idea fromi and Ino
oano are the only two people who can do
that and they're both goats yeah yeah
exactly